madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
une semaine après le naufrage du
pétrolier aucune opération de pompage en
raison de la météo
premières victimes de la marée noire les
oiseaux mazoutés la colère de
l'association greenpeace
les élections législatives en russie les
communistes selon les premières
estimations tiendrait 28% des voix ce
n'est pas une surprise
le maire de moscou a été réélu au total
107 millions d'électeurs appelés à se
prononcer c'était macao est
officiellement retourner dans le giron
de la chine populaire cérémonie
officielle en présence du numéro un
chinois et du président portugais cinéma
avec la sortie mercredi prochain d'une
comédie américaine la musette et sharon
stone
asim signé albert brooks je vous
proposerai ce journal en partant
directement large de la vendée en pleine
mer là où sont portés par un vent
violent ces nappes de fioul lourd qui
s'approche des côtes
une myriade de noble de 50 à 150 mètres
de diamètre pour certaines entre deux
eaux évolue à l'heure actuelle à 50 km
au sud-ouest de l'île d'yeu et à 100 km
de l'île d'oleron les navires étrangers
qui vont appuyer les remorqueurs
français sont en train d'arriver sur
place en raison d'une mauvaise météo
aucune opération de pompage n'a pu se
dérouler ce dimanche une nouvelle
journée inopérantes
comme a pu le constater cet après midi
une équipe de france 2 en liaison au
milieu de l'océan
jacques cardoze emmanuel bec ici en
pleine mer à quelques mètres seulement
du début des plaques de fioul et à
quelques mètres de moi
l'action qui est évidemment pour le
moment se contente de se positionner au
milieu de la zone on est parti ce matin
à 4h de lorient et le voyage a été très
très dur vous le voyez cette mer est
vraiment démonter des creux de 4 ha à 5
à 5 m et un vent de force 7 ce qui rend
bien entendu impossible toute opération
comprend d'ailleurs ce qui a pu se
passer ces jours derniers avec la marine
nationale qui n'a pas pu réaliser toutes
ses opérations de pompage
on le voit ici nous avions voulu le
vérifier effectivement c'était
réellement impossible pour eux de
réaliser ces opérations de pompage et la
nab va donc continuer à dériver vers les
terres maintenant est ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que ce matin un avion
des douanes a survolé la zone
afin de réaliser un certain nombre de
relevés pour connaître l'emplacement de
ces plaques parce que
ces plaques évolue très vite elles ne
sont plus qu'à 45 km de lisieux
une semaine après le naufrage du
pétrolier maltais la colère de
l'association greenpeace qui depuis ce
matin s'est rendu d'abord sur le lieu où
s'est brisé en deux le tanker erika pour
ensuite gagner les nappes de pétrole qui
continuent de dériver de migraine
ministre de l'environnement critiqué ce
matin la logique du profit maximal
demandant un renforcement des règles du
trafic maritime
un simple pis-aller selon l'association
greenpeace lui cars ou jean luc boussard
à 45 ans paul horsman n'en est pas à sa
première catastrophe pétrolière
ce biologiste spécialiste des pollutions
en milieu marin a déjà mené campagne
pour greenpeace surnombre de marée noire
semaines après le naufrage de l'erika
il est venu porter haut et fort la
contradiction aux uns ceux qui se
veulent rassurants comme aux autres ce
qu'ils réclament de nouveaux règlements
il ya déjà des lois en place la
difficulté tient plus au temps aux
moyens qu'il faut consacrer en mer pour
faire respecter ces lois
et puis surtout ce sont les blocages que
l'on rend compte quand on veut tout
simplement de les forcer à la loi et
paul horsman de rappeler que la plus
forte amende actuelle pour réprimer les
dégazages revient en moyenne quatre fois
moins cher qu'un nettoyage de cuves dans
les règles après négociation avec la
préfecture maritime
son hélicoptère a obtenu l'autorisation
de survoler la zone où repose l'épave de
l'erika une première depuis la
catastrophe
surprise devant la nappe laissé sans
surveillance le mans ils attendent que
quelque chose se produise mais regardez
là se souvient il se fasse le feu
observé qu'il y ait ce genre de
catastrophes chaque heure chaque jour
par absence de programme pour récupérer
les 20 mille tonnes de fuel renfermé
dans l'épave
absence de ramassage des plus petites
galettes paul horsman dénonce une
mobilisation plus fait selon lui annonce
que d'actions concrètes même lorsque
total promet un milliard de francs final
il part c'est leur pétrole qui flotte
là c'est à eux de s'en occuper d'essayer
de le récupérer ils ont assez d'argent
pour faire ça où sont ils on veut nous
mener les premières observations
indépendante après la catastrophe de
l'erika
greenpeace a réalisé une opération
symbolique mais à entendre le constat
l'association écologiste ne devrait pas
s'arrêter là
les premiers préparatifs aux sables
d'olonne avec l'installation de deux
balises qui permettront de fixer des
barrages flottants cas de marée noire
ces mesures préventives à l'entrée du
port s'inscrivent dans le cadre du plan
polmar terre un navire spécialisé a posé
ces deux blocs de béton août 1,2 point
d'ancrage qui sont également disposer
dès demain à l'entrée de différents
ports vendéens d'après les dernières
informations de météo france
il n'y aurait pas de risque avant cinq
jours la vendée reste menacée même si le
pétrole semble davantage s'orienter vers
la charente maritime une information
bien sûr à confirmer si la marée noire
n'a pas encore atteint les côtes en
revance les premiers oiseaux mazoutés
ont
fait leur apparition à belle-ile il sera
ensuite acheminés vers un centre de
soins spécialisé sur le continent louis
carzou gens mais vous sert de cartons
ramassés chez les commerçants une paire
de gants et puis ils s'en vont pour des
heures evelyne etienne font partie des
bénévoles de la maison de la nature de
belle-ile-en-mer
depuis la catastrophe de l'erika leur
quotidien c'est ça
arpenter les plages les criques à la
recherche d'oiseaux victimes du pétrole
fouillez jusqu'aux moindres recoins où
leur sac peut les abandonner et
lorsqu'il en reperd 1 il faut encore
pouvoir l'attraper
ce qu'on arrive à ramassées sur les
plages c'est les oiseaux complètement
épuisé donc c'est ceux qui ont le moins
de chance finalement restauré
on pourrait ramasser cela je fais parce
que gagner pour lui bon débarras d'un
matin
ciro ferrara les passants pouvaient vous
voyez ça arrive parce qu'on voulait
les années sans catastrophe si l'on
ramasse un par semaine depuis vendredi
la moyenne s'approche de la dizaine par
jour
les pingouins des macareux ou des
guillemots comme celui là alors sur
l'île on mobilise toutes les bonnes
volontés
le pot de terre contre un polluant
d'enfer vous devez récupérer ou sur
toutes les plages y en a partout à venir
ce matin je n'ai récupéré 8
et puis à 3 et puis on en récupère dans
les prochains jours mon avis on aura
encore une bonne trentaine de la grotte
de l'apothicairerie à la pointe de
poules dont c'est toute la façade ouest
et sud de belle île qui est
potentiellement exposés à la menace et
nappes d'hydrocarbures un risque
d'autant plus grand que l'île est un
lieu d'hibernation pour certaines
espèces d'oiseaux et de réserve en été
pour d'autres encore
et la ligue pour la protection des
oiseaux auraient déjà recensés ce matin
plus de 150 oiseaux mazoutés des oiseaux
provenant des quatre départements
témoignant ainsi d'une pollution à
grande échelle de l'écosystème marin
c'est du moins ce qu'indique
l'association présidée par alain
bougrain dubourg le naufrage du
pétrolier erika nous amène à nous
interroger sur l'état de navigation de
ses navires de plus en plus délabrés
remis rapidement en état des navires
moins coûteux pour les armateurs et pour
ceux qui les affres est l'exemple de ce
bateau battant lui aussi pavillon
maltais qui restaient à quai pendant
cinq ans au havre considérée comme une
épave
après travaux il reprend pourtant du
service et s'apprêtent à transporter 13
mille tonnes de sucre jusqu'en séries
enquête elle à margaux eric lemasson
delphine de tri c'est l'histoire d'une
métamorphose en 94 après des avaries en
mer le kif ont bon dos et remorqué
d'urgence dans le port du havre
les inspecteurs des affaires maritimes
le déclare alors inapte à la navigation
la salle des machines est hors d'usagé
le bateau est en piteux état les
réparations sont estimées à plusieurs
millions de francs
mais l'armateur une compagnie angolaise
est aux abonnés absents
le kif ont bon dos et son équipage vont
donc rester abandonné sur un quai du
havre pendant cinq ans finalement l'état
français décide cette année de payer le
retour des marins dans leur pays
le navire est mis aux enchères 2
millions 5 il ne trouvera preneur qu'à
quatre cent mille francs tout semble dès
lors le destiner à la casse mais plutôt
que de revendre la ferraille le nouveau
propriétaire décide contre toute attente
de le remettre à flot le 24 novembre
dernier
le kif ont bon dos rebaptisé dans
l'intervalle le tango des mets le cap
sur dunkerque
une métamorphose surprenante qui
inquiète aujourd'hui les associations
écologistes
c'est un vieux bateau est pire que
l'erika
c'est un bateau qui est absolument pas
entretenues et qui est resté désarmé une
mob il faut comprendre ce que ça veut
dire est ce que est ce que quelqu'un
reprendrait un camion qui est resté
abandonné sur la voie publique pendant
cinq ans l'équipage a effectué lui-même
la majorité des travaux puis le tango
des a passé quinze jours dans un
chantier du havre pour les affaires
maritimes il est aujourd'hui
parfaitement en règle
le nouveau propriétaire a fait les
réparations pour lui demander et affamés
puce qu'il ne fallait peut-être pour le
faire le faire le rendre tout à fait
sérieux nous l'avons vérifié par deux
inspections successives et à nous
pouvons lui chuté bonne mère reste des
détails
les inspecteurs des affaires maritimes
ne contrôle que le fonctionnement du
navire mais sa structure l'épaisseur de
la coque sont contrôlées elles par des
sociétés de classification privé comment
savoir si certaines ne se montre pas
moins regardante que d'autres la société
polonaise qui inspectait le tango des
travaille régulièrement avec des
pavillons de complaisance comme le
pavillon maltais or le nouveau
propriétaire un armateur grec a
justement choisi d'immatriculer son
bateau non pas en grèce met à mal
ainsi les vieux cargo reprenne t-il du
service à 20 ans passés le tango des
entame une seconde vie mais après tout
ils ne transportent que des cycles
l'accueil était à l'étranger avec les
élections législatives en russie 107
millions d'électeurs appelés à
renouveler les députés de la douma
une élection qui aura valeur de test
avant les présidentielles de juin
prochain
depuis hier soir les premiers bureaux de
vote ont ouvert leurs portes sur ce
territoire immense qui s'étend de
l'extrême orient au caucase sur onze
fuseaux horaires les premières
estimations sont attendues en fin de
soirée le maire de moscou serait réélu
avec 70 % des voix gilles rabin franck
brisset c'est un petit village perdu de
la banlieue de moscou
perdu au point qu'il porte toujours un
non communiste grâce noyer le rouge
pourtant à krasnaya ce dimanche
d'élections est d'abord le jour de la
saint nicolas
vous avez déjà voté nous pourquoi
en russie il ya deux églises celle des
évêques et celle des prêtres dans les
villages de la foi est forte et l'église
est respectée peut être parce que les
peuples et prêtres partage jour après
jour la vie et la grande pauvreté des
villageois gc sans nous ont mis sur la
bonne voie maintenant on va voter
en général les visent ne se gêne pas
pour mettre ses oies est sur la bonne
voie c'est à dire le plus souvent celle
du pouvoir en place
mais partagent nos coutumes qui veut
vivre en mieux voilà on en a c'est de
vivre ce mal
alors pour qui sont elles venues voter
c'est notre secret
contre ça peut pas rester comme ça vous
avez voté oui pour qui pour mes préférés
c'est qu'ils vous préférez ceux qui
peuvent nous aider
au même moment à 40 km de là mais dans
un autre monde boris eltsine voter ce
dont nous avons besoin c'est d'une dumas
qui votent les lois et ne fasse pas de
politique
bref d'une du mat de sin heureusement
pour la démocratie
plus personne à krasnaya n'écoute ce que
dit encore le vieux président évidemment
nous ce qu'on veut a dû se taire c'est
terminé nous on ne nous entend pas
personne ne prête attention
c'est très dur maintenant se traiterait
des fessées depuis le début du conflit
en tchétchénie ils sont des milliers à
avoir trouvé refuge en ingouchie et
c'est de cette république voisine qu'ils
ont participé au vote aujourd'hui des
élections un peu particulière organisée
tant bien que mal au dernier moment car
même si les tchétchènes sont en guerre
contre les russes officiellement ils
sont citoyens de la fédération de russie
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
dorothée olliéric dj da
c'est jour d'élection au fond de
karaboulak
venez voter venez tous voter les
réfugiés tchétchènes timidement s'avance
vers ce bureau de vote itinérants
partout dans la grande fédération de
russie
les électeurs dont deux bulletins de
vote les parce que leur république est
déchiré par la guerre
les tchétchènes ne peuvent se prononcer
que sur le scrutin fédéral pour qui
allez vous voter poser c'est bien la
patrie iabloko jirinovski deux partis
staliniens
alors choisissez le geste symbolique
la femme est nerveuse elle en appelle à
dieu qui doit aider le peuple héroïque
des tchétchènes voyage
moi je ne vote pas pour la russie mais
pour les gens bien il en reste encore un
peu en russie et pourtant les soldats
russes ont bombardé ma maison bonjour ma
famille
ils ont tous situés à malines amelot
depuis ils ont même rasé être village
demain on associe robes la chronique il
leur fait encore confiance
oui je crois encore genre d'espoir 3000
réfugiés ville dans ce camp de toile à
midi environ 40 % avaient déjà voté mais
beaucoup de tchétchènes 0
catégoriquement pour qui voulez vous je
vote aujourd'hui aura des élections de
la république indépendant ou de
tchétchénie alors je voterai mais pour
l'heure les bombes russe la mine chaque
jour un peu plus l'indépendance de la
tchétchénie
les votes de ces réfugiés blessés semble
presque dérisoire je voulais arrêter la
guerre coin pour que les gens view dans
le calme pour que tout se passe bien
lyon n'en porte quelques croître à ses
yeux de tous c'était jour d'élection au
camp de karaboulak comme en 95 les
élections législatives se déroulent sur
fond de guerre en tchétchénie
et comme en 95 la plupart des réfugiés
tchétchènes qui ont voté l'ont fait pour
dire non à la guerre et cette journée
électorale n'aura marqué aucune pause
dans les combats en tchétchénie
l'aviation russe bombardait grozny
aujourd'hui des combats sporadiques et
la périphérie de la capitale
alors qu'un autre front s'est ouvert au
sud dans les régions montagneuses comme
en témoigne l'un des rares journalistes
français présents dans cette zone
renaud girard notre confrère du figaro
les forces russes ont débarqués par
hélicoptère
les troupes spéciales des parachutistes
pour bloquer la frontière avec la
géorgie pour bloquer la route de
ravitaillement la dernière aussi rester
aux seychelles
mon enfant avait comparé verglas
d'artillerie très clairement les les
russes pour l'instant arrive à bloquer
la frontière donc les commandes ou rue
sur la frontière fiennes toujours
puisque aucun passage mais possible
laitiers tienne prétendent en avoir tué
17 l'année dernière mais ce qui est
certain c'est qu'une bataille furieuse
en lui donc sur cette frontière entre la
georgie là tu utilises écart letizi ne
veulent évidemment rouvrir cette route
de ravitaillement vital proulx et puis à
marchetti dans cette ville de cette
scène abusent de réfugiés auraient été
mitraillé par un avion russe faisant
sept morts et 40 blessés au sri lanka
deux jours de l'élection présidentielle
deux attentats dans la ville de colombes
vue hier soir
32 morts et 110 blessés dont la
présidente sortante qui a été blessé au
moment de l'explosion
elle est toutefois hors de danger
aujourd'hui le premier attentat est un
attentat suicide perpétré par une femme
en plein coeur de la capitale
il ya tout juste trois heures macao
officiellement regagnait le giron de la
chine populaire après quatre siècles
d'administration portugaise
pour l'occasion le numéro un chinois
avaient fait le déplacement
cérémonie sous haute sécurité isabel
bechler tristan le braz dès 17h au
palais du gouverneur premier symbole
on a mené le drapeau portugais le
général vasco vieira l'a porté à son
coeur pour clore ces neuf ans comme
représentant de l'état portugais macao
et abandonner cette dernière poussière
d'empiré colonial européen
en asie on avait versé quelques larmes
plus privé au moment où la famille du
gouverneur prenait congé du personnel
chinois et macanais de la résidence
mais la rupture entre macao le portugal
a été consommée à minuit au moment le
président sans faille on le fait aux
enfants soumis un scellé la formule un
pays deux systèmes pour le petit
territoire de 450 mille habitants après
quatre cent quarante deux ans de
présence coloniale macao aborde ainsi le
28e
avec 50 ans d'autonomie sous le drapeau
rouge de brik 50 ans pour retourner à la
mère patrie sans perdre son âme
deux ans et demi après hong kong la
chine vient donc d'éradiquer les
derniers vestiges coloniaux qui
l'obsédait mais la prochaine épine que
pékin veut se retirer du pied s'appelle
taïwan et là la réunification risque
d'être considérablement plus
problématique
les futurs hauts fonctionnaires chinois
de macao ont été formés au pas de course
ces derniers mois pour remplacer les
portugais qui sont sur le départ
c'est le cadre des forces de police dans
la tâche est particulièrement rude dans
cette île où la criminalité est très
présente
reportage sur place et abel bessler très
sain le bras sous la botte de
l'instructeur portugais très officiers
supérieurs de police en formation tous
chinois
ils encadreront bientôt une partie des
5000 agents des forces de sécurité de
macao depuis 88
cette école de police a permis de
remplacer peu à peu les militaires
portugais par des autochtones
après la rétrocession je rentre au
portugal on travaille maintenant là bas
dans l'armée il est temps de partir
c'est l'histoire qui s'impose après
quatre cent quarante deux ans de
présence coloniale
le gros des troupes des jeunes recrues
ce sont 104 futurs policiers gardiens de
prison pompiers et autres gardes côtes
où la dette école a été créée sur mesure
pour recruter et former localement
des officiers de police et ainsi
répondre aux besoins des forces de
sécurité qui faussent ils seront garde
côtes par exemple à traquer dans le
détroit de zhuhai immigration
clandestine et contrebande
cette zone dite du port intérieur est
quasi incontrôlable avec ses centaines
d'embarcations et la chine continentale
à quelques encablures c'est par là
qu'arrivent les bataillons de petite
prostituée de la campagne chinoise et
gravitent autour des hôtels et des
casinos
les règlements de comptes entre
proxénète contribue largement à la
criminalité violente dans souffre macao
toute la périphérie du jeu est une zone
à haut risque qui excite beaucoup de
convoitises d'autant que le système
judiciaire portugais représentent un
microclimat dans la région non nous
avons la certitude est que la chine va
respecter les systèmes macanais qu'elle
ne touchera pas au système judiciaire
actuel et qu'elle conservera un autre
code pénal dans lequel la peine de mort
ne figure parmi avec moi que mon corps
dans l'enfer du jeu un monopole dans les
mains d'un seul homme les triades ont
encore de beaux jours devant elle après
la rétrocession du petit territoire
elles devront toutefois se méfier de
l'ardeur toute nouvelle de la police
chinoise qui aura à coeur de faire mieux
et plus répressifs que l'administration
portugaise sortante
le pape jean paul ii se rendra en terre
sainte en mars prochain il s'agira de la
première visite d'un souverain pontife
dans cette région depuis 1964 jean paul
ii du
21 au 26 mars prochain visitera les
lieux saints notamment bethléem qui sous
l'autorité palestinienne au venezuela
après les dramatiques inondations qui
ont dévasté le pays le bilan ne cesse de
s'alourdir
des centaines de morts des milliers de
disparus et quelque vingt mille blessés
des messes en ce dimanche ont été dites
à travers tout le pays et la population
commence à enterrer ses morts gilles
marini
ils sont des milliers dans l'attenté
d'une évacuation la région de vargas
près de caracas est celle qui a le plus
souffert
il manque d'eau de nourriture mais
aujourd'hui le ballet des hélicoptères
vient enfin de commencer les dizaines
d'appareils qui font le va et vient
entre la zone sinistrée et la base
militaire de mega tient à 50 km de
caracas
ici se coordonne un début de coopération
internationale américain cubains
mexicains sont là d'autres pays vont
intervenir
nous avons reçu aussi un appel d'une
organisation non gouvernementale
française se propose de fournir 30 mille
repas par jour durant un mois
nous sommes en train d'organiser
concrètement cette opération sur la
bande côtière coupés du reste du pays
c'est la marine qui intervient ce navire
militaire a pu embarquer trois mille
personnes mais il il faudra revenir dans
tout le pays le nombre de victimes
autant que les autorités puissent
vraiment les skis mais s'élèverait à 25
mille morts et disparus 150000 sans abri
dans ce cimetière sur les collines de
caracas pour enterrer les morts au plus
vite ont fait appel aux volontaires
localement nous allons travailler 24
heures sur 24 par solidarité avec le
peuple de caracas et nous avons aussi
besoin de son aide comme il faut creuser
de plus en plus de tongs une des
volontaires pour nous renforcer
il faut faire vite après plusieurs jours
de chaos
le pays est en effet menacées par les
épidémies en france les départs sur la
route des vacances pour cette période
des fêtes de noël avec ce carambolage
sur l'autoroute a10 ce matin trois
autocars et deux voitures sont entrées
en collision deux des autocars
transportaient des enfants mais aucun
n'a été blessé
reste que ces accidents ces accidents au
total ont appliqué près de 150 personnes
faisant un mort et 20 blessés dont deux
graves
du côté des stations la saison de sports
d'hiver s'annonce plutôt bien avec la
reprise la croissance
les stations cette année pour la
première fois depuis longtemps eu du mal
à trouver des employés saisonniers une
pénurie d'emplois qui se comptent par
milliers reportage emilie lançant
frédéric basket
d'habitude au ski sous la neige que l'on
craint de ne pas avoir cette année ce
n'est pas le cas ce qui manque ce sont
plutôt les saisonniers dialing et rémy
arrive tout juste de paris ils font
partie de ces perles rares pour les
patrons qui vont travailler cinq mois en
station niveau du décor des jaf du matin
on se lève on n'a pas la grisaille
parisienne et le métro on va l'oublier
pendant six mois déjà
en bon rang voire à croire que tout le
monde n'est pas de cet avis car ici chez
soul world résidence on trie toujours
les cv pour trouver les cinq personnes
manquantes à la réception et au serveur
du bar
oui je pense intéressant parce qu'il
vient lui 35 cette année il ya moins de
demande qu'à l'accoutumée et beaucoup de
candidats sont sans qualification
alors certains ne trouvent pas et les
journées de travail deviennent alors
pour le moins acrobatique ou par mon ami
qui travaille aux grilles m aider à la
plonge mon beau frère en salle ma soeur
et moi une amie à la cuisine c'est à
dire aucune personne qui sortait de
travailler dans l'établissement parce
qu'on trouve pas du personnel c'est
précisément pour ne pas se retrouver
dans cette situation que certaines
chaînes ont décidé de fidéliser leurs
saisonniers
chez pierre & vacances on propose des
contrats à temps partiel annualisé
l'hiver à la montagne laissé à la mer
les employeurs n'ont ainsi plus à courir
après leurs candidats c'est un gain de
temps c'est également une garantie pour
les salariés d'avoir un même employeur
qui lui garantit jusqu'à huit mois et
demi voire parfois davantage de travail
sur l'année
car si les saisonniers se font si rares
à l'anpe d'albertville comme ailleurs
c'est que leur condition reste précaire
et qu'avec la reprise économique ils ont
désormais peut-être un peu plus le choix
de la neige des sapins à une superbe
patinoire en plein paris le trocadéro à
l'heure de la savoie pour ce marché de
noël ce village des enfants
il me grey cette fin de semaine laurence
de chefs myriam métaoui
ni dans les halles fini dans les
pyrénées mais encore dans le jura des
jeunes acrobates de la neige c'est que
là tout simplement au trocadéro en face
de la tour eiffel une piste de ski mais
également une patinoire où petits et
grands peuvent découvrir les joies de la
glisse en plein air au coeur de paris
d'habitude c'est plutôt dans l'intérieur
et placé à l'extérieur on sait assez
agréable surtout que là ya beaucoup de
soleil vous à gauche puisque cela fait
un fils ambiance que c'est pas pareil on
s'attendait pas à voir ça et weick
parfum ou même très telus corp tout pour
se croire à la montagne avec de vrais
chalets en bois des vrais sapins et même
de la vraie neige 500 tonnes avec un
ravitaillement de trois ou quatre
camions par jour
c'est en tout cas le programme prévu car
pour le moment il en manque en cause
mais m 2e pas un vague de camions neige
qui vont venir avec de la vraie neige
sauf que pour l'instant ils sont
bloquées dans l'école qu'avait
conditions climatiques dans les pyrénées
sont un peu difficiles du retard pour la
neige mais pas pour les enfants quand il
s'agit de vacances les couvertes de
cd-rom teinture ou encore maquillage
c'est le programme dans les chalets
réserver au moins sportifs et si jamais
les chutes de neige ne sont pas au
rendez-vous à noël les enfants auront de
toute façon la sensation d'être à la
montagne
la ruée dans les grands magasins presque
une tradition pour ce dernier dimanche
avant noël
l'effet millénium auxquels s'ajoutent
les cadeaux de noël ont été amenés en
nombre les parisiens une véritable cohue
dans certains grands magasins les
vitrines alléchantes et les rayons les
plus prisées comme les jouets et les
nouvelles technologies
une page sportive avec ans qui cette
victoire française ces jeunes chenal qui
a remporté le slalom géant de coupe du
monde d'alta badia en italie par
ailleurs régine cavagnoud accompli une
belle performance en s'emparant de la
troisième place marque mise en loge dire
que ses adversaires le trouvait trop
émotif cette fois joël chenal n'a craqué
qu'après l'arrivée de la deuxième manche
et sa victoire c'est difficile d'y
croire en étant 7e à la 1re je fais
vraiment un très bon ski à la deuxième
avec quelques petites fautes mais ça ça
tout le monde en fait c'est vrai que
d'attendre que ça puis d'être tout le
temps premier sur le tableau ça m'était
jamais arrivé et puis c'est carrément
rêve pour moi toi et pour être convaincu
totalement joël chenal a dû relire
plusieurs fois la feuille des résultats
grâce à une deuxième manche parfaite
il a battu herman mayer et le suisse von
grünigen il rejoint ingemar stenmark
rien - le suédois et luce coeur du
siècle au palmarès de ce géant
autre surprise française du week end à
st moritz en suisse
la troisième place en super-g de régine
cavagnoud celle qui avait été gravement
blessé certains y verront un miracle
d'autres la récompense d'un travail
acharné mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
c'est la troisième fois qu'elle monte
sur le podium cette saison
la ville de marseille s'est réveillé ce
matin avec un goût amer après les
incidents qui ont opposé hier les
supporteurs de l'om aux forces de
l'ordre
une rencontre qui a mal tourné alors que
marseille perdait face à lens alexandre
kara ces derniers temps les hommes de
l'om n'aime pas beaucoup joué au stade
vélodrome et entendre l'accueil de leurs
supporters on les comprend d'ailleurs à
lire les banderoles dans les tribunes
si claire ses supporters là
ne supporte plus personne à marseille
hier soir si l'om s'est incliné face à
lens le résultat est devenu presque
anecdotique tant l'ambiance dans le
stade était détestable
les buts de porato bombardé aux
fumigènes et toujours ces inscriptions
haineuses et insultant
qu'ils soient déçus on est tous déçu les
joueurs ou les premiers dirigeants on
est déçu et c'est pas on continue à
avoir un climat aussi hostile comment
pour redresser la barre à défaut de
victoire s'il ya bien un spectacle
devenu classique ce sont les
affrontements entre supporters et crs
mais aussi ses joueurs qui s'enfuit et
quitte le stade par des chemins dérober
de peur de se voir agressé la mère
il faut tout jeter la faute est une
faute il était là je vois pas qui c'est
qui peuvent sauver le bateau du port il
y avait des internats retapisser t'aider
c'était des hommes qui savent mettrent
attendait désormais les dirigeants
cherchent à ménager leurs supporters
nous aussi semble douter de la
motivation de certains joueurs et il en
tire les conséquences
on est quatre et six joueurs qui vont
qui vont bouger entre autres mettre un
restructurer un peu là là là l'équipe
c'est à dire mettre des étaient des
joueurs aguerris
on parle déjà des départs de dugarry ou
pires l'om devrait être l'un des
principaux acteurs du mercato le grand
marché du transfert de l'intersaison
une chose est sûre il faudra du temps
pour tout reconstruire
cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
d'une comédie signée albert brooks avec
que la belle sharon stone la muse
l'histoire d'un scénariste en mal
d'inspiration qui tombe sous le charme
de sa muse nicole corps d'une anglais
travaillent à main
et dans une ville vouée au cinéma comme
los angeles
une telle femme un succès fou auprès de
tous les créateurs en panne d'idées
j'espère que tu as visité disent que ça
manque de vivacité
l'argument c'est que j'ai perdu ma
vivacité peut éventuellement faire
j'étais jeune il trouve sa muse
tous les créateurs de beethoven à
léonard de vinci tous ont besoin d'une
mule tous sont à la recherche d'un
regain d'inspiration
j'ai ma propre mu
elle va lui coûter très très cher elle
aime les bijoux les palaces le luxe elle
est très exigeante et les coûts que
l'inspiration ne peut s'épanouir que si
tout fonctionne à merveille
donc comme elle veut et il lui faut donc
voiture et laurie survêtement
teinturerie tout le monde doit lui
passer ses quatre volontés
et un pyjama très moelleux le plus haut
possible et où tu sais bien ce truc vous
savez on fait comme ça la lumière du
cash c'est un petit peu loin de moi
gk
elle pourrait être une fusée elle
pourrait croire qu'elle est la fille de
zeus
elle a tellement le désir que tout le
monde soit au meilleur de ses capacités
son intention est de rendre heureux les
plus grands réalisateurs viennent la
consulter et lui offre des bijoux c'est
la tradition ainsi james cameron
j'allais oublier
rien de rien tout à l'heure vous allez
aimer c'est avec les droits de petite
amie que je les payais comment se
fait-il que malgré tous ces ingrédients
pimenté par des acteurs en pleine forme
la comédie ne fonctionne pas au mieux
manque de rythme manque de mu peut-être
les objets d'art du siècle une
exposition au palais des congrès qui
réunit les grands noms qui ont marqué
l'époque des créations signées dior
hermès chanel ou balmain reportage
marie-pierre samitier fit l'objet cela
embarquement immédiat pour l'an 2000
avec les maîtres cellier de chez hermès
ou vito cette exposition met en scène
très joliment les métiers d'art à la
française on démontre que la csa pour
avoir la discrétion qu'on a tous devant
aval des renforts en se demandant à qui
peut bien appartenir le bagage
c'est fabuleux
le fac de cuistots en promenade avec ses
casseroles fait flouer et à côté dans le
jardin extraordinaire la dinanderie la
plus raffinée
les plats d'argent sortent des griffes
de christophe les fleurs de soie de la
maison du lait pour nice heures des
grands couturiers héberge le bébé du
troisième millénaire troisième
millénaire un bébé dans le chou bon
pourquoi pas moi je verrais plutôt un
bébé par internet
ce fauteuil s'appelle sismique
une création cette année d'un inconnu de
30 ans régis mailhot il est vendu 4800
francs revanche ce globe terrestre des
cristalleries saint louis n'est pas à
vendre
il a presque 200 ans gravé pour charles
10 une pièce unique comme ses dentelles
de normandie d'après des croquis du
xviie siècle cette dentellières coup
depuis l'âge de 6 ans moi je suis en
effet talent surtout des jeunes des
pièces uniques ou des objets en série
qui force l'admiration
je consacre je vais vraiment le tour
demain n'est pas prêt de schubert ça
fait très plaisir
cette table d'hervé van der straeten et
la conjugaison de trois talents un
ébéniste un dinandier et un hacker avec
les broderies d'un certain jean françois
lesage notable à jouer créer aujourd'hui
dans la grande tradition du xviie siècle
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres les
élections législatives en russie
le maire de moscou a été réélu au total
107 millions d'électeurs étaient appelés
à se prononcer
ces faits macao est officiellement
retourner dans le giron de la chine
populaire cérémonie solennelle en
présence du numéro un chinois et du
président portugais
une page qui se tourne après quatre
siècles d'administration portugaise dans
un instant la météo patrice drevet 21 55
e soleil avec sophia loren et roger
hanin l'erreur 45 le dernier journal
lève mettait de master 50 dans les 4
vérités gérard morin recevra le
violoniste didier lockwood à 20 heures
françoise laborde j'aurai le plaisir de
vous retrouver à partir du 31 décembre
pour les journaux de cette fin d'année
merci de votre attention excellente
soirée sur france 2